clustering in machine learning welcome
to Simply learn in this video we will
see what is clustering and understand K
means clustering in machine learning so
before we begin consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us so what
is gin's clustering gan's clustering is
an unsupervised learning algorithm in
this case you you don't have labeled
data unlike in supervised learning so
you have a set of data and you want to
group them and as the name suggests you
want to put them into clusters which
means objects that are similar in nature
similar in characteristics need to be
put together so that's what K means
clustering is all about the term k is
basically is a number so we need to tell
the system how many clusters we need to
perform so if K is equal to 2 there will
be two clusters if K is equal to three
three clusters and so on and so forth
that's what the k stands for and of
course there is a way of finding out
what is the best or Optimum value of K
for a given data we will look at that so
that is K means cluster so let's take an
example K me's clustering is used in
many many scenarios but let's take an
example of Cricket the game of cricket
let's say you received data of a lot of
players from Maybe all over the country
or all over the world and this data has
information about the runs scored by the
people or by the player and the wickets
taken by the player and based on this
information we need to Cluster this data
into two clusters batsmen and Bowlers so
this is an interesting example let's see
how we can perform this so we have the
data which consists of primarily two
characteris itics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsman score runs
there will be of course a few Bowlers
who can score some runs and similarly
there will be some batsmen who will Who
would have taken a few wickets but with
this information we want to Cluster
those players into batsmen and Bowlers
so how does this work let's say this is
how the data is so there are information
there is information on the Y AIS about
the Run scored and on the x-axis about
the wickets taken by the players so if
we do a quick plot this is how it would
look and um when we do the clustering we
need to have the Clusters like shown in
the third diagram out here so we need to
have a cluster which consists of people
who have scored High runs which is
basically the batsman and then we need a
cluster with people who have taken a lot
of wickets which is typically the the
Bowers there may be a certain amount of
overlap but we will not talk about it
right now so with C in's clustering we
will have here that means K is equal to
2 and we will have two clusters which is
batsmen and Bowlers so how does this
work the way it works is the first step
in cayman's clustering is the allocation
of two centroids randomly so two points
are assigned as so-called centroids so
in this case we want two clusters which
means K is equal to 2 so two points have
been randomly assigned as centroids keep
in mind these points can be anywhere
there are random points they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids centroid means it's a central
point of a given data set but in this
case when it starts off it's not really
the centroid okay so these points though
in our presentation here we we have
shown them one point closer to these
data points and another closer to these
data points they can be assigned
randomly anywhere okay so that's the
first step the next step is to determine
the distance of each of the data points
from each of the randomly assigned
centroids so for example we take this
point and find the distance from this
centroid and the distance from this
centroid this point is taken and the
distance is found from this centroid and
this Cent and so on and so forth so for
every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the centrer position of this
data set Central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point or the actual Cent is
determined and the original randomly
allocated ated centroid is repositioned
to the actual centroid of this new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will will'll keep it simple
so this process is continued till the
centroid repositioning stops and that is
our final cluster so this is our so
after iteration we come to this position
this situation where the centroid
doesn't need any more repositioning and
that means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
Clusters with a cide so this process is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points what are the types
of clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and K means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are in
hierarchical clustering the Clusters
have a tree like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom of
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively large clusters so for
example we have a b CDE e f we start by
combining B and C form one cluster d and
e form one more then we combine d and f
one more bigger cluster and then add BC
to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top- down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have a b CDE e f
we first take that as a single cluster
and then break it down into a b c d e
and f then we have partitional
clustering split into two subtypes k
means clustering and fuzzy c means in K
means clustering the objects are divided
into the number of clusters mentioned by
the number K that's where the K comes
from so if we say k is equal to 2 the
objects are divided into two clusters C1
and C2 and the way it is done is the
features or characteristics are compared
and all objects having similar
characteristics are clubbed together so
that's how K means clustering is done we
will see it in more detail as we move
forward and fuzzy seans is very similar
to K means in the sense that it clubs
objects that have similar
characteristics together but while in C
in's clustering two objects cannot
belong to or any object a single object
cannot belong to two different clusters
in C means objects can belong to more
than one cluster so that is the primary
difference between K means and fuzzy c
means so what are some of the
applications of kain's clustering kain's
clustering is used in a variety of
examples or variety of business cases in
real life starting from academic
performance diagnostic system search
engines and wireless sensor networks and
many more so let us take a little deeper
look at each of these examples academic
performance So based on the scores of
the students students are categorized
into a b c and so on clustering forms a
backbone of search engines when a search
is performed the search results need to
be grouped together the search engines
very often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster stuff so clustering
especially K means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on K means
clustering so distance measure tells how
similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is you ucan distance there is
Manhattan distance then we have squared
ukian distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by K means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these what is ukian distance measure
this is nothing but the distance between
two points so we have learned in high
school how to find the distance between
two points this is a little
sophisticated formula for that but we
know a simpler one is square root of of
Y2 - y1 s + X2 - X1 s so this is an
extension of that formula so that is the
ukian distance between two points what
is the squared ukian distance measure
it's nothing but the square of the ukian
distance as the name suggests so instead
of taking the square root we leave the
square as it is and then we have
Manhattan distance measure in case of
Manhattan distance it is the sum of the
distances across the x- axis and the Y
AIS and note that we are taking the
absolute value so that the negative
values don't come into play so that is
the Manhattan distance measure then we
have cosine distance measure in this
case we take the angle between the two
vectors formed by joining the points
from the origin so that is the cosine
distance measure okay so that was a
quick overview about the various
distance measures that are supported by
K means now let's go and check how
exactly K means clustering works okay so
this is how K Main's clustering works
this is like a flowchart of the whole
process there is a starting point and
then we specify the number of clusters
that we want now there are couple of
ways of doing this we can do by trial
and error so we specify a certain number
maybe K is equal to 3 or four or 5 to
start with and then as we progress we
keep changing until we get the best
clusters or there is a technique called
elbow technique whereby we can determine
the value of K what should be the best
value of K how many clusters should be
formed so once we have the value of K we
specify that and then the system will
assign that many centroid so it picks
randomly that to start with randomly
that many points that are considered to
be the centroids of these clusters and
then it measures the distance of each of
the data points from these centroids and
assigns those points to the
corresponding centroid from which the
distance is minimum so each data point
will be assigned to the centroid Which
is closest to it and thereby we have K
number of initial clusters however this
is not the final clusters the next next
step it does is for the new groups for
the Clusters that have been formed it
calculates the mean position thereby
calculates the new centroid position the
position of the centroid moves compared
to the randomly allocated one so it's an
iterative process once again the
distance of each point is measured from
this new centroid point and if required
the data points are reallocated to the
new centroids and the mean position or
the new centroid is calculated once
again if the centroid moves then the
iteration continues which means the
convergence has not happened the
clustering has not converged so as long
as there is a movement of the centroid
this iteration keeps happening but once
the centroid stops moving which means
that the cluster has converged or the
clustering process has converged that
will be the end result so now we have
the final position of the centroid and
the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid I
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means all these points are very close to
each other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10 10 clusters and for each value of
K the within SS is measured and the
value of K which has the least amount of
within SS or WSS that is taken as the
optimum value of K so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the Y AIS the within sum of squares
or WSS and on the x- axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have K is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the with's value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within SS value and that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of K increases the decrease the rate of
decrease will not be so high it will
continue to decrease but probably the
rate of decrease will not be high so
that gives us an idea so from here we
get an idea for example the optimum
value of K should be either two or three
or at the most four but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing ing the value in
WSS because that pretty much gets
stabilized okay now that we have got the
value of K and let's assume that these
are our delivery points the next step is
basically to assign two centroids
randomly so let's say C1 and C2 are the
centroids assigned randomly now the
distance of each location from the
centroid is measured and each point is
assigned to the centroid which is
closest to it so for example these
points are very obvious that these are
closest to C1 whereas this point is far
away from C2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to C1 will be
assigned to C1 and these points or
locations which are close to C2 will be
assigned to C2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of C1 and this is part of C2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
C1 and C2 are not the centroids they've
been randomly assigned points and only
thing that has been done was the data
points which are closest to them have
been assigned to them but now in this
step the actual centroid will be
calculated which may be for each of
these data sets somewhere in the middle
so that's like the mean point that will
be calculated and the centroid will
actually be positioned or repositioned
there same with C2 so the new centroid
for this group is C2 in this new
position and C1 is in this new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance Still
Remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this so this
point earlier was closer to C2 because
C2 was here but after recalculating
repositioning it is observed that this
is closer to C1 than C2 so this is the
new grouping so some points will be
reassigned and again the centroid will
be calculated and if the centroid
doesn't change so that is a repetative
process iterative process and if the
centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
C1 and C2 as the centroids these data
points as a part of each cluster so I
hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of K
means clustering so let's take a look at
the K means clustering algorithm let's
say we have X1 X2 X3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split the
into K clusters or we want to create K
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick K points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of X1
from C1 1 from C2 C3 each of the
distances we calculate and then find out
which distance is the lowest and assign
X1 to that particular random centroid
repeat that process for X2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids C1
C2 C3 up to CK and find which is the
lowest distance and assign X2 to that
particular Cent same with X3 and so on
so that is the first round of assignment
that is done now we have K groups
because there are we have assigned the
value of K so there are K centroids and
uh so there are K groups all these
inputs have been split into K groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the main
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected centroids will
now change and they will be the main
positions of these newly formed K groups
and once that is done we once again
repeat this process of calculating the
distance right so this is what we are
doing as a part of step four we repeat
step two and three so we again calculate
the distance of X1 from the centroid C1
C2 C3 and then see which is the lowest
value and assign X1 to that calculate
the distance of X2 from C1 C2 C3 or
whatever up to CK and find whichever is
the lowest distance and assign X2 to
that Centro and so on in this process
there may be some reassignment X1 was
probably assigned to Cluster C2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
X1 is assigned to C1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps two and three till the position of
the centroids don't change or stop
changing and that's when we have
convergence so let's take a detailed
look at at each of these steps so we
randomly pick K cluster centers we call
them centroids because they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids so we let us name them C1 C2
up to CK and then step two we assign
each data point to the closest Center so
what we do we calculate the distance of
each x value from each C value so the
distance between X1 C1 distance between
X1 C2 X1 C3 and then we find which is
the lowest value right that's the
minimum value we find and assign X1 to
that particular centroid then we go next
to X2 find the distance of X2 from C1 X2
from C2 X2 from C3 and so on up to CK
and then assign it to the point or to
the centroid which has the lowest value
and so on so that is Step number two in
Step number three We Now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of Step number two we
now have all the points all the data
points grouped into K groups because we
we wanted to create K clusters right so
we have K groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have K
groups but remember the initial values
of the C1 C2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step
three we actually calculate the centroid
of each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as I said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have K
groups but the number of items and
actual assignment may be different from
what was in step two here okay so that
might change then we perform step three
once again to find the new centroid of
this new group so we have again a new
set of clusters new centroids and new
assignments we repeat this step two
again once again we find and then it is
possible that after iterating through
three or four or five times the centroid
will stop moving in the sense that when
you calculate the new value of the
centroid that will be same as the
original value or there will be very
marginal change so that is when we say
convergence has occurred and that is our
final cluster that's the formation of
the final cluster all right so let's see
a couple of demos of uh K mean's
clustering we will actually see some
live Demos in uh python notebook using
python notebook but before that let's
find out what's the problem that we are
trying to solve the problem statement is
let's say Walmart wants to open a chain
of stores across the State of Florida
and uh it wants to find the optimal
store locations now the issue here is if
they open too many stores close to each
other obviously the they will not make
profit but if they if the stores are too
far apart then they will not have enough
sales so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like Walmart which
is an e-commerce giant they already have
the addresses of their customers in
their database so they can actually use
this information or this data and use ke
means clustering to find the optimal
location now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the Live
code I wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this block we are
basically importing all the required
libraries like numpy matplot Leb and so
on and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses for Simplicity sake we will
just take them as some data points then
the next thing we do is quickly do a
scatter plot to see how they are related
to each other with respect to each other
so in the scatter plot we see that there
are a few distinct groups already being
formed so you can actually get an idea
about how the cluster would look and how
many clusters what is the optimal number
of clusters and then starts the actual K
means clustering process so we will
assign each of these points to the
centroids and then check whether they
are the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct
clusters and um which is we can say that
this is how the population is probably
distributed across Florida State and uh
the centroids are like the location
where the store should be the optimum
location where the store should be so
that's the way we determine the best
locations for the store and that's how
we can help Walmart find the best
locations for the store stores in
Florida so now let's take this into
python notebook let's see how this looks
when we are learning running the code
live all right so this is the code for K
means clustering in Jupiter notebook we
have a few examples here which we will
demonstrate how K means clustering is
used and even there is a small
implementation of kin's clustering as
well okay so let's get started okay so
this block is basically importing the
various libraries that are required like
M plot lib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in psychic learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing thing okay so that's exactly what
we are doing here we are using make
blobs and we can specify how many
clusters we want so centers we are
mentioning here so it will go ahead and
so we just mentioned four so it will go
ahead and create some test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides now
from here onwards we will basically run
the standard K means functionality that
is readily available so we really don't
have to implement K means itself the K
means functionality or the the function
is readily available you just need to
feed the data and we create the Clusters
so this is the code for that we import K
means and then we create an instance of
K means and we SP specify the value of K
this ncore clusters is the value of K
remember K means in K means K is
basically the number of clusters that
you want to create and it is a integer
value so this is where we are specifying
that so we have K is equal to four and
so that instance is created we take that
instance and as with any other machine
learning functionality fit is what we
use the function or the method rather
fit is what we use
to train the model here there is no real
training uh kind of thing but that's the
call okay so we are calling fit and what
we are doing here we are just passing
the data so X has these values the data
that has been created right so that is
what we are passing here and uh this
will go ahead and create the Clusters
and uh then we are
using after doing uh fit We Run The
predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster it
belongs to all right so it will name the
Clusters maybe this is cluster one this
is two three and so on or will actually
start from zero cluster 0 1 2 and three
maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in Yore
K means when we call that is what it
does and we can take a quick look at
these Yore K means or the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation one
maybe this is for observation two
observation three and so on so we have
how many about I think 300 samples right
so all the 300 samples there are 300
values here each of them the cluster
number is given and the cluster number
goes from 0 to 3 so there are four
clusters so the numbers go from 0 1 2 3
so that's what is seen here okay now so
this was a quick example of generating
some dummy data and then clustering that
okay and this can be applied if you have
proper data you can just load it up into
X for example here and then run the C so
this is the central part of the cin
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter andore
clusters and that is also the value of K
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the K
means algorithm so we will just walk you
through I will walk you through the code
uh at each step what it is doing and
then we will see a couple of more
examples of how K means clustering uh
can can be used in maybe some real life
examples real life use cases all right
so in this case here what we're doing is
basically implementing g means
clustering and there is a function for a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what K means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that cide so
that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
kin's clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers and then we put this in a loop
and we take it through an iterative
process for each of the data points we
first find out using this function
pairwise distance argumen for each of
the points we find out which one which
Center or which uh randomly selected
centroid is the closest and accordingly
we assign that data or the data point to
that particular Cent roid or cluster and
once that is done for all the data
points we calculate the new centroid by
finding out the mean position with the
the center position right so we
calculate the new centroid and then we
check if the new centroid is the
coordinates or the position is the same
as the previous centroid the positions
we will compare and if it is the same
that means the processor has converged
so remember we do this process till the
centroids or the centroid doesn't move
anymore right so the centroid gets
relocated each time this reallocation is
done so the moment it doesn't change
anymore the position of the centroid
doesn't change anymore we know that
convergence has occurred so till then so
you see here this is like an infinite
Loop while true is an infinite Loop it
only breaks when the centers are the
same the new center and the old Center
positions are the same and once that is
uh done we return the centers and the
labels now of course as explained this
is not a very sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position will keep moving but in the
change will be very minor so in that
case also with that is actually
convergence right so for example the
change is
01 we can consider that as convergence
otherwise what will happen is this will
either take forever or it will be never
ending so that's a small flaw here so
that is something additional checks may
have to be added here but again as
mentioned this is not the most
sophisticated implementation this like a
kind of a rough implementation of the K
means clustering okay so if we execute
this code this is what we get as the
output so this is the definition of this
particular function and then we call
that find underscore clusters and we
pass our data X and the number of
clusters which is four and if we run
that and plot it this is the output that
we get so this is of course each cluster
is represented by a different color so
we have a cluster in green color yellow
color and so on and so forth and these
big points here these are the centroids
this is the final position of the
centroids and as you can see visually
also this appears like a kind of a
center of all these points here right
similarly this is like the center of all
these points here and so on so this is
the example or this is an example of a
implementation of K means clustering and
uh next we will move on to see a couple
of examples of how K means clustering is
used in maybe some real life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use K
means clustering to perform color
compression
we will take a couple of images so there
will be two examples and uh we will try
to use Cam's clustering to compress the
colors this is a common situation in
image processing when you have an image
with millions of uh colors but then you
cannot render it on some devices which
may not have enough memory uh so that is
the scenario where where something like
this can be used so before again we go
go into the python notebook let's take a
look at quickly the the code as usual we
import the libraries and then we import
the image and uh then we will flatten it
so the reshaping is basically we have
the image information is stored in the
form of pixels and uh if the image is
like for example 427 by 640 and it has
three colors so that's the overall
dimension of of the of the initial image
we just reshape it and um then feed this
to our algorithm and this will then
create clusters of only 16 clusters so
this this colors there are millions of
colors and now we need to bring it down
to 16 colors so we use K is equal to 16
and U this is how when we visualize this
is how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible color colors
the input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just some
compress it to 16 colors so this is how
it would look when we compress it to 16
colors and this is how the original
image looks and after compression to 16
colors this is how the new image looks
as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost though
the image quality is defitely reduced a
little bit so this is an example which
we are going to now see in Python
notbook let's go into the python notbook
and once again as always we will import
some libraries and load this image
called flower. jpg okay so let we load
that and this is how it looks this is
the original image which has I think 16
million colors and uh this is the shape
of this image which is BAS basically
what is the shape is nothing but the
overall size right so this is 427 pixel
by 640 pixel and then there are three
layers which is this three basically is
for RGB which is red green blue so color
image will have that right so that is
the shape of this now what we need to do
is data let's take a look at how data is
looking so let me just create a new cell
and show you what is in data basically
we have captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here all right so let's take a look at
China what are the values in China and
uh if we see here this is how the data
is stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about for for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is the these
values are large the numbers are large
so we need to normalize them to between
0er and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide China
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this a piece of code
and this is the shape so we now have
also yeah what we have done is we
changed using reshape we converted into
the three-dimensional into a
two-dimensional data set and let us also
take a look at
how let me just
insert probably a cell here and take a
look at how data is looking all right so
this is how data is looking and now you
see this is the values are between zero
and one right so if you earlier noticed
in case of china the values were large
numbers now everything is between 0 and
one this is one of the things we need to
do all right so after that the next
thing that we need to do is to visualize
this and uh we can take random set of
maybe 10,000 points and plot it and
check and see how this looks so let us
just plot this and so this is how the
original the color the pixel
distribution is these are two plots one
is red against Green and another is red
against Blue and this is the original
distribution of the color so then what
we will do is we will use K mean's
clustering to create just 16 clusters
for the various colors and then apply
that to the image now what will happen
is since the data is large because there
are millions of colors using regular K
means maybe a little time consuming so
there is another version of K means
which is called mini batch K means so we
will use that which is which processes
in the overall concept Remains the Same
but this basic basically processes it in
smaller batches that's the only thing
okay so the results will pretty much be
the same so let's go ahead and execute
this piece of code and also visualize
this so that we can see that there are
this this is how the 16 colors uh would
look so this is red against Green and
this is red against Blue there is uh
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything
anything like that now we apply this the
newly created colors to the image and uh
we can take a look how this is uh
looking now we can compare both the
images so this is our original image and
this is our new image so as you can see
there is not a lot of information that
has been lost uh it pretty much looks
like the original image yes we can see
that for example here there is a little
bit uh it appears a little dullish
compared to this one right because uh we
kind of took off some of the finer
details of the color but overall the
high level information has been
maintained at the same time the main
advantage is that now this can be this
is an image which can be rendered on a
device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the Summer Palace in China and we repeat
the same process this is a high
definition color image with millions of
colors and also uh
three-dimensional uh now we will reduce
that to 16 colors using K means
clustering and um we do the same process
like before we reshape it and then we
cluster the colors to 16 and then we
render the image once again and we will
see that the color the quality of the
image slightly deteriorates as you can
see here this has much finer details in
this which are probably missing here but
then that's the compromise because there
are some devices which may not be able
to handle this kind of high density
images so let's run this code in Python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again uh
we can take a look at the shape which is
427 by 640 by 3 and this is the new data
would look somewhat like this compared
to the flower image so we have some new
values here and we will also bring this
as you can see the numbers are much big
so we will much bigger so we will now
have to uh scale them down to values
between 0er and one and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and uh
do that and reshape it okay so we get a
two- dimensional Matrix and uh we will
then as a next step we will go ahead and
visualize this how it looks the the 16
colors and this is basically how it
would look 16 million colors and now we
can create the Clusters out of this the
cin clusters we will create so this is
how the distribution of the pixels would
look with 16 colors and then we go ahead
and uh apply this and visualize how it
is looking for with the with the new
just the 16 color so once again as you
can see this looks much richer in color
but at the same time and this probably
doesn't have as we can see it doesn't
look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done uh using
K's clustering and we have also seen in
the previous examples of how to
implement K means the code to roughly
how to implement uh kin clustering and
we use some sample data using blob to
just execute the C's clustering thank
you moan that was really informative now
on to Richard to help you learn more
algorithms so the decision tree one of
the many powerful tools in the machine
learning library begins with a problem I
think I have to buy a car so in making
this question you want to know how do I
decide which one to buy and you're going
to start asking questions is a mileage
greater than 20 is a price less than 50
will it be sufficient for six people
does it have enough airbag anti-lock
brakes all these questions come up then
as we feed all this data in we make a
decision and that decision comes up oh
hey this seems like a good idea here's a
car so as we go through this decision
process using a decision tree we're
going to explore this maybe not in
buying a car but in how to process
data staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here